we're talking about the poster here
we're just coming in hot what do female
comedians talk about the craft the road
how insecure we are about our necks
that's what we talk about it is just it
your face is Flawless perfect looks like
a piece of delicious pound cake but the
neck these angles it's just they kill me
bral it's brutal bral the number one
thing I get when people meet me in
person is they're always like so they'll
say like you're so much prettier in
person or like you're a lot thinner in
person tiny and I'm like I'm 14 I'm a
I'm a normal siiz gal but C the camera
specifically 4K it doesn't that sitcom
camera doesn't love me 10bs to the only
yes I just did the uh Great American
bake off and they just put out the
trailer today and it's literally me
hovering over like a pound cake with my
seven chins and I'm like this is the
best day of my life and I'm like why did
I do this to myself it's such a bummer
it's like a bummer not what you look
like in person but there this angle is
brutal brutal y That's why we do comedy
I guess this is the poster for The
[Music]
Sopranos like that's not you this is
literally the Cable Guy this is Capone
this is the poster for Capone Al
Capone me you look and I just showed her
another poster for The Improv thing that
I'm doing where it was like I was had
because when you do ponytail pulls
everything back was feeling very
snatched and they pick an angle that's
just from below so I've got the M Mr
Potato Head my is like center of my face
all J Leno chin and these guys can
always cover it with the beard that's
what pisses me off the guys no matter
what they get have a wonky eye but
because they have a beard or a goatee it
covers it up well whoever wants to
snatch me up let me know now we're doing
the snatch up of the neck yeah we're
we're gonna tape it we're gonna do
whatever yeah I don't you know time I
was working with this uh actress who I
really looked up to as a as a tot I
worked with her in a TV show and we're
on it's a you know live studio audience
and I hug her first scen
uh First Take I go to Huger and then I
just hear
like like Clank Clank Clank like on the
ground and I look down and I see like a
like a chip clip it's like a metal chip
clip that she had used was holding her
NE
hold can you imagine she would just go
put it under and then do the scene and
it fell to the ground and she's like we
had to go backstage and put it back on I
mean it was pretty that's going to be me
H it worked it worked worked so you're
saying you're saying it works I'm saying
we're going on Shark Tank next week but
it is really tricky picking out what
you're going to wear for a special I
don't like it when you're watching a
special the guys just look like they're
um just left Trader Joe's or work at
Trader Jo on a suit why are you in
shorts yeah why are you wearing two
different socks you just left Sports
Authority those aren't even open anymore
there the tag is still on your Under
Armour hoodie are you returning this
after the the little the the minimal
effort that these men are allowed to get
away with meanwhile I got a chip clip on
my neck and they just roll in with a
pair of new Nike Dunks and A Cargo short
and they're like gonna be on Joe
Rogan kill me okay so you um uh special
is brilliant I didn't get to hear a lot
about the husband this special it's
going to be that's what I'm shooting
next week it's an hour roast of my
husband and our first year of marriage
love it so you are in a place where you
are about to aspiring to be mother
that's coming soon I'm going to be able
to help you with that at some point I'm
so grateful for that you have no idea
but now I need you to help me be a wife
what do I need to do so you're on the
you're on the market look I'm I do
things out of order wa trash till I die
so having a baby and now I'm ready to be
a wife okay great what do I have to do
all right so to be a wife um you really
don't have to be good at a lot of things
right like I I mean I married the
typical like Italian guy who I don't
have those shoulders to give blowj jobs
I'm
great just go ahead let this circulate
on the internet I'm good at it um okay
so you here's the thing what I say this
is actually decent marriage advice
marriage is a marriage is a partnership
so the way whenever I can't get my
husband to do what I need I I sit him
down and I talk about it in like Layman
turns of like we're running a business
okay yep if we were going into a sales
pitch and you didn't have your
PowerPoint put together and you hadn't
been working on it we would lose a deal
and you're punching your hand and I'm
punching my hand like that get power
together so anytime I instead of nagging
you because when you got it when you got
to manipulate guys to do what you want I
say this is a this is a Business
Partnership you didn't come to the table
you didn't close the deal right so if
I'm on the road and I'm doing crazy and
I come home and nothing's been done or
anything that I asked him to do I can do
two things I can either nag and write
his or I just reframe it and I'm like
how do we run this as a business soon as
you start talking like you know boy math
or whatever you just say business you
know interesting they up my husband
connects to that hey we're down six
points we're down six points yes now
you're still touring like an animal I'm
still touring yeah I thought I was going
to take some time off and now they're
like let's how do you do your podcast
you do it when you I do it when I'm home
in Atlanta okay I'm home for one day a
week I go into the studio I record the
podcast and then I'm back on the road
it's insane so yeah uh trying to get
this TV show picked up let's go um yeah
writing I want to act more and do all
that but we're I'm on the road I'm about
to shoot my next special next week nice
so that's great in Atlanta which will be
amazing and then just did that thing
work out that we're not going to say us
y uhhuh we're yeah we're figuring out
yeah great so it's all been good good
I'm just shaking my tits for cash just
doing the damn thing I'm gonna say
you're glowing that's so you are and I'm
not as soon as I walked in though I said
my tits look like the map of the subway
in New York it's just blue how how are
your nipples nipples do wild wild they
also when the baby is
breastfeeding the saliva in the baby's
mouth gives feedback to the nipple on
what nutrients to prod more of of what
the baby's lacking we're that's insane
we it's a simulation yeah what have you
been craving like a rack of ribs sex
with
strangers